[Music]
this great big story is made possible by
Lexus experience amazing
[Music]
I'm Adrenalina Kassadin see dodgy [ __ ]
in Paris cases the premiere is about
supra me L combustion can concentrate
the small time
[Music]
I know me Andre de Souza cars 10
Cuarenta honest I'm a problem areas on
TV - so Chivas adage you have his own 15
much black kind of a yugioh Paciello
tautology
[Music]
Javy Chipper Jones eh oh god poor Khan
Quattro's oh god originaly mughal
chemicals are they on display
Kirikou Kevin ties into yoga doctor his
elusive his own a baller
ting gives presents oriental for its own
[Music]
the post of kisser
Peggy avante g g g patronage cost
instrumentos chemical and food because
Randy forum says messages you eat the
pizza industry trade RVD we will barely
be the perfect messenger of Jamal
ostrich format they don't Christina it
sentiment about Alegria was some
decision that my pursuers devote
arsenide Robin I meant vomit rubella
they oughta suspect achievers artists
orange because knowledge matters
vegetarian conclusive to the travail to
the football
[Music]
smell we know when it's good and we know
when it's bad but there's a woman in
Scotland I'm joining them who can smell
the unsalables went on fire joy Milne is
the only known person who can smell
Parkinson's disease I have an extremely
sensitive sense of smell I can smell it
meanly on the forehead and the back of
the neck to Joy it has a greasy musky
odor it is just a heavy smell to me she
first noticed it on her late husband les
Milne 12 years before he was diagnosed I
just thought he was tired and he wasn't
shouting enough it wasn't very welcome
of course me saying to mug you're
smelling it wasn't until she attended a
conference with other Parkinson's
patients that she realized the smell was
something more when I walked into the
room I saw gosh these other people smell
the same as last us at the end of the
meeting I stood up and said why were
they not investigating the smell of
Parkinson's no-one was investigating
because no one else could smell it
researchers set up a controlled
experiment to test Joy's nose she was
asked to distinguish a set of t-shirts
worn by those with and without the
disease she insisted one of the subjects
in the control group had the musky scent
the man rang about eight months later
and said I've got Parkinson's so I had
pre diagnose somebody by the time most
people are diagnosed 80 to 90 percent of
the damage is done
so Joy's mission is to help scientists
improve early detection methods if they
can find these people earlier it would
stop this anguish that would make such a
difference
I started painting music just because I
would try to explain synesthesia so many
times it never quite made as much sense
to describe it verbally so I thought it
would be best just to put it on canvas
just because I've always been an artist
and it made it much easier for people to
be able to understand it my name is
Willis McCracken and I am a synesthetic
artist synesthesia is a neurological
condition where your brain is basically
cross-wired so certain stimuli will come
in and it'll create the wrong response
in my brain so from me that's listening
to music and it's translated into color
in my head I'm going to paint
superstition by Stevie Wonder I love a
song superstition just because it's
dynamic and funky and just fun and
expressive whenever I start a piece I
have to listen to the song first to even
know what kind of colors I'd like to use
there are some songs that I hate that I
like the way that they look a little bit
like a lot of pop music it can be pink
and purple and you know just all these
fun bright colors but songs not that
good so one or the other I appreciate it
somehow you know you kind of really have
to be in the right vibe to be able to
paint if you're not in the right vibe
you're not gonna make anything good
I think the prettiest onra of music is
jazz music I love blues and golds and
whites and it just seems very pearly and
iridescent a little bit when I listen to
Etta James at last the thing that stuck
out most to me was just her voice at the
very beginning when she goes into the
last
then it's just a very bright and but
also warm sort of feeling and very kind
of classic jazzy which jazz music
generally has a very gold and blue sort
of look to it
music has always been a very big part of
my life and my older brother is very
musical
and when I think back of him playing the
guitar for me I think of the colors of
what those memories are I was always a
little disappointed because I was never
very musically inclined it was really
cool to have a way to bring music into
you know my life in a different sort of
way
[Music]
by describe it as having bubblegum and
once it's lost all its flavor you have
just a piece of rubber that you chew
over and over again that is essentially
what food is like for me when I put food
into my mouth my name is agent Malik and
I have lost my sense of taste I suffered
a cold and I started getting a metallic
taste in my mouth
once that finally left took my sense of
taste with it it took me a few weeks to
actually identify that it was my taste
because I could smell perfectly I only
eat foods now which spend very little
time in the mouth because I don't
extract any flavor the idea of a
chocolate bar or a steak though where
you chew it in order to bring out the
juices and the flavors of it
there's no enjoyment from it and so I
find myself eating very light foods like
salads and rice and also I used the
advantage of adding herbes in order to
make the smell sensation quite enjoyable
I also find these spice very important
spice is not actually something you
taste it's something you feel it gives
us a sort of tingle in my mouth you end
up with a rather peculiar eating pattern
that people look at you funny because
you're putting chilies on your breakfast
cereal and you've put in a a mustard
sauce on pretty much a lot of the food
you eat and almost three years now we're
still not otherwise rooster why it's
gone or getting my sense of taste back
[Music]
I cannot see but I can hear the world
around me meet Brian he's known as the
world's best totally blind mountain
biker when I was younger I had
functional vision and I played sports I
had dreams of becoming a professional
athlete and then suddenly when he was 14
he completely lost his sight over the
course of 3 months his optic nerves
inexplicably failed and all he could see
was darkness he wasn't able to bike ride
or participate in the sports he once
enjoyed I couldn't play hockey I had to
stop rollerblading couldn't read the
classroom board anymore my world had
shrunk he had to find a new way to
navigate the world he found his cane
limiting but when he learned to make a
tongue click his world changed again for
the better and it wasn't long until he
ventured back outdoors
I really missed bike riding and I really
wanted to be active I just didn't know
how to do it as a blind rider it was a
goal for me to get off the tandem and
have the experience of being able to
pilot my own bike it all starts with a
zipped I'm a sighted person would
attaches to their frame and angle it
into the bike wheel the bike wheel would
make noise in a sound to follow while we
would still actively click eventually
Brian was able to mountain bike alone
and without the zip tie when I'm riding
my bike down a mountain it's the same
thing bats are using echolocation I can
make my active sonar signal by making a
tongue click I start off with trying to
find the object furthest in the distance
and then piece the world together with
things closer and closer Brian has to
enter an almost meditative state and
remain extremely focused
everything has to leave my brain and
those sounds are painting a picture of
my head a vivid world of acoustic images
he didn't keep his passion to himself
though he's helped teach over thousands
of people to hear their world a little
bigger this is a teachable thing anybody
can do this and I'm happy to show them
riding my bike was something I never
thought I'd be able to do again and now
that I'm doing it it serves as a great
example to challenge preconceived ideas